[Music]
one of the most recognizable landmarks
near Dallas is of course AT&T Stadium
it's home to the Dallas Cowboys and
starting this weekend it's going to be
hosting the NCAA Final Four which is
very exciting
so all this week to honor the Final Four
taking place here in Texas we're doing
what anyone would do we're shooting full
court baskets outside AT&T Stadium with
the help of a catapult we stole from
Mark Cuban's bedroom it's a full court
3-point shot now instead of shooting a
basketball boring anyone can do that
we're launching things that are uniquely
Texan last night we launched a 72-ounce
steak from the Big Texan tonight we're
launching a baby that was born just last
week at Baylor Medical Center and is
already a basketball prodigy very
talented baby who plays basketball and
there he is
he's ready to go he's intense basketball
prodigy 5 4 3 2 1
that's gotta hurt you know what that's a
Texas baby that baby stuff let's try it
again let's do it there's the baby
he is tough he's got no head but he's
going boy
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so close in and out it had his head he
too got it in I'm not giving up cuz
that's not what you do in Texas we're
gonna shoot one more item
it's very Texan that's right ladies and
gentlemen Willie Nelson's back taxes
that's right 32 million dollars 32
million dollars in back taxes that
Willie owes the government let's see if
we can do this for
[Applause]
here's the coolest part we teamed up
again with AT&T to bring you our new
conan 360 camera you got to check it out
it's revolutionary technology allowing
our viewers to watch all those catapult
shots in 360 degree video right on their
computer tablets or phone let's take a
look at the conan 360 replay you've seen
that only the shot but all the board
cameras sitting around and that amazing
Texas sky you can watch the shots from
any angle with this breakthrough
technology so thanks to our friends at
AT&T for bringing you Kona 360 now
you'll be able to experience our show in
a whole new way we'll be right back